i remember when i was 20 years old i was
a very difficult character i was
audacious sometimes arrogant and
sometimes annoying i had trouble getting
along with my peers and i was constantly
getting into trouble trying to prove
other people wrong to be honest with you
i can't blame my behavior only on me and
my character i need to also blame the
people who were my biggest influencers
at the time albert camille franz kafka
friedrich nietzsche and charles bukowski
all played their part in the emergence
of this peculiar persona of mine i can't
really explain what was wrong with me i
was studying electrical engineering and
instead of looking up to people like
stephen hawking or albert einstein i was
trying to follow advice promoted by
lonely czech novelists radical german
philosophers and american pulp fiction
writers many years later although
audacity turned into respect arrogance
into understanding and annoyance into
proactive listening i still find myself
reading and being highly influenced by
those people i guess you can change your
actions your behavior and your goals but
you can change who you really are our
choices in life do not align completely
with our needs and beliefs usually we
make choices based on necessity advice
from elders or social norms especially
at the fragile age of 20 unless you have
been immersed in a specific lifestyle
defined by concrete goals and actions at
a younger age you will rarely find
yourself doing what you really want or
at least what you think that you want
and that's probably the main reason
behind most people's confusion at this
stage they find themselves in a
situation where they do something that
they don't want but at the same time
they don't really know what they want
they have some vague ideas and thoughts
that could lead them somewhere but they
don't really know which idea is the best
and most importantly how to put it into
practice and this frustrating reality
can empower the emergence of peculiar
personalities or personas in our instant
gratification culture it's easy to
forget that most personal achievements
do not occur as a single static event in
time but rather as long gradual events
that we're hardly aware of as they are
happening it's like a game you get
accustomed to the main principles and
you develop more skills as you get
immersed in the mechanics of the game at
some point you develop unconscious
competence and everything makes sense
life oftentimes feels the same and just
like every other game life needs its own
strategy guide and its own stages
character and personality development is
a topic people don't learn at school it
is a gradually evolving process that
occurs while we experience different
events in life i would like to divide
these events into two categories static
events and dynamic events we can easily
understand the difference between the
two if we focus on their origin and also
on how they relate to each other
generally speaking static events are
considered events that occur almost
conventionally their lifespan is quite
lengthy and they usually lead to a low
growth mental state characteristic
examples include school a tedious job a
stagnant romantic relationship a toxic
friendship dynamic events on the other
hand are events that result after our
own personal will and pursuit their
lifespan varies depending on how well we
can evaluate their benefit in our lives
and they usually play an important role
in our character development typical
examples include an adventurous trip the
development of a creative idea
cultivating deep connections activism
the process of learning a new skill
reading and writing to name a few
understanding the difference between
static and dynamic events is a process
that will eventually lead to a mentality
shift and consequently to a reality
shift you will start experiencing new
events and new ideas that will
ultimately lead to a strong and
congruent personality realizing the
existence of this personality is
probably the most important step towards
understanding what you really want
apparently the most challenging headache
for people who have defined their
personality or are in the process of
defining their personality is that they
find themselves facing difficulties
deciding upon their preferred skills and
options they might be good at many
things and can't unnecessarily focus on
just one pursuit and that's probably the
reality for most people nowadays
consequently another challenging
question arises how do you decide what's
best for you a great way to tackle this
abstraction is to adhere to a concept
known as systems thinking the main idea
behind it is that in order to manage the
system effectively you need to focus on
the interactions of its parts rather
than their behavior taken separately see
yourself as a whole that exists of
different parts these parts are your
skills in order for the whole to work
effectively all the parts need to work
synergistically let's take the example
of an entrepreneur an entrepreneur
isn't good at one skill called
entrepreneurship
entrepreneurship is a mixture of skills
it is a combination of knowledge in
areas like marketing business persuasion
sales copywriting and many more
obviously an entrepreneur cannot master
all these skills he can however achieve
a great level of ability in each one of
them so he can successfully manage their
system by pursuing a certain skill we
can discover synergies with other skills
we were oblivious to before defining
what you really want is a process that
manifests itself in a systematic way
thinking in systems can actually resolve
many unsolved problems or events that we
considered problems in the first place
a mental model is a way of looking at
the world put simply mental models are
the set of tools that you use to think
creatively each mental model offers a
different framework that you can use to
look at life or an individual life
problem in order to exhibit the value of
mental models i'm going to investigate
an area where mental models usually
shine the area of productivity the
models are many for the purposes of this
video i will present my favorite mental
models which i consider my most powerful
allies in my attempt to become more
productive the two-minute rule was
suggested by author james clear and aims
to inspire action taking there are two
parts in the two-minute row part one is
if it takes less than two minutes then
do it now this piece of advice is
suggested by david allen and his
best-selling book getting things done if
you take a minute to consider how many
things we put off that could be done in
two minutes or less you will be amazed
typical examples include taking out the
garbage washing your dishes after you
eat
cleaning up clutter creating your task
list cleaning your email box part two is
when you start a new habit it should
take less than two minutes to begin with
it when it comes to habit performing
tasks the most difficult part is the
takeoff that small time frame in the
beginning of the task until you get
immersed in it and enter flow state the
idea behind this rule is to force
yourself to stain the task for at least
two minutes even if you find it
extremely difficult to do so for example
you want to become a better writer
start writing for two minutes and you
will often find yourself writing for an
hour you want to become a better
programmer start coding for two minutes
and you will often find yourself coding
for hours you want to start working out
more
do a warm-up with puss-ups for two
minutes and you will get fired up for
the rest of the training session you get
the idea these two minutes are enough to
get your mind from a passive state to an
active state once it gets into that
state immersion ensues
president dwight eisenhower was famous
for his productivity skills inspired by
him stephen cavey in his book the seven
habits of highly effective people
introduced the eisenhower decision
matrix which is a tool that can help one
prioritize tasks based on four
possibilities urgent and important which
are tasks you will do immediately
important but not urgent which are tasks
you will schedule to do later
urgent but not important
tasks you will delegate to someone else
neither urgent nor important tasks that
you will eliminate
i find the eisenhower matrix extremely
useful when it comes to your daily task
list once you have listed all the tasks
for the day you can add them in the
matrix based on importance
the matrix will give you a more concrete
view of your tasks i'm not a huge warren
buffett fan for ideological reasons but
i like the following story and i find
the rule
quite important one day mike flint
buffett's personal airplane pilot was
talking about his career priorities with
him and buffett asked him to go through
a three-step exercise step 1 buffett
asked flint to write down his top 25
career goals step 2. then buffett asked
flint to review his list and highlight
his top 5 goals step 3 at this point
flint had 2 lists the five items he had
highlighted
were list a and the 20 items he had not
highlighted were list b
flint confirmed that he would start
working on his top five goals right away
and that's when buffett asked him about
the second list and what about the ones
you didn't circle flint replied well the
top five are my primary focus but the
other 20 come in a close second they're
still important so i'll work on those
intermittently as i see fit they are not
as urgent but i still plan to give them
a dedicated effort to which buffett
replied no
you've got it wrong mike everything you
didn't highlight just became your avoid
at all cost list no matter what these
things get no attention from you until
you've succeeded with your top five this
is a powerful idea
focus is the driver of excellence we
can't overwhelm our reality with too
many goals narrowing down and focusing
on things that really matter is the
quintessence of productivity
back in 2010 after reading eckhart
tolle's power of now for the first time
i came face to face with a very daunting
challenge toe suggests that negative
emotions are creations of our mind that
if understood and processed accurately
can be tamed and even eliminated looking
back to my early 20s i remember that
most of my unpleasant and also
embarrassing moments were a result of my
inability to understand and manage my
emotions the challenge toll set about
was probably the most impactful moment
in my life thus far through a lot of
research and personal experimentation i
came to understand that a healthy
emotional state can be sustained by
investing in the following areas
i was about to use the term emotional
resilience to define the first area of
importance but i like the term
anti-fragility better the word
antifragility was coined by nassim taleb
in his book antifragile things that came
from disorder as talib suggests in his
book anti-fragility is beyond resilience
or robustness the resilient resist
shocks and stays the same the
anti-fragile gets better anti-fragility
gives you room to get something positive
out of negative events in your life
whereas resilience doesn't
where a resilient character just endures
an anti-fragile character fights back
best way to develop anti-fragility is
through exposure to uncomfortable
situations and also psychotherapy in
order to understand yourself and your
potential better
when you exercise your body releases
chemicals called endorphins endorphins
interact with the receptors in your
brain that reduce your perception of
pain endorphins also trigger a positive
feeling in your body similar to that of
morphine for example the feeling that
follows a run or a workout is often
described as euphoric that feeling known
as a runner's high can be accompanied by
a positive and energizing outlook on
life as a result exercising can reduce
stress ward off anxiety and feelings of
depression boost self-esteem and improve
sleep with regards to reading deciding
to go through the process of opening
your mind to another person's thoughts
and ideas can help you improve your
emotional state in a couple of ways
firstly you increase your knowledge in
different areas and you become less
prone to confusion when facing questions
concerning complex topics secondly if
you identify with the ideas promoted by
the writer
you somehow experience a feeling of
self-validation you understand that
you're not the only person having those
thoughts or concerns and if you come
from a place of emotional desperation
this process can help you eliminate it
and also give you hope for a brighter
future
serotonin is a powerful neurotransmitter
that allows us to experience feelings of
elation
the main sources of serotonin can be
divided into the following three
categories emotional and physical
connection with other people is critical
to serotonin release self-confidence and
self-validation are probably the main
feelings that indicate the impact of
this release on our lives we all know
that a bad diet affects our health
negatively and mental health suffers as
a result there is a second brain inside
our gut there lies the enteric nervous
system which has neurons similar to the
ones brain has the enteric nervous
system uses more than 30
neurotransmitters just like the brain
and in fact 95 percent of the body's
serotonin is found in the bowels what
you eat affects this system
fun can be anything from parting to
extreme sports when you decide to work
on your productivity levels you will
realize that burnout is inevitable you
need fun in order for the required
serotonin levels to be reached and also
to help the mind recover from a burnout
state caused by too much work
despite our most gentle intentions the
mere structure of society and the
complexity of our emotional and social
world
make our life conditions difficult to
manage in the midst of this battle
people can only maintain emotional
stability by staying detached and
managing their interactions with
patience and empathy as robert greene
very elegantly states in the 33
strategies of war our successes and
failures in life can be traced to how
well or how badly we deal with the
inevitable conflicts that confront us in
society the common ways that people deal
with them trying to avoid all conflict
getting emotional and lashing out
turning sly slime manipulative are all
counterproductive in the long run
because they are not under conscious and
rational control and often make the
situation worse strategic warriors
operate much differently they think
ahead toward their long-term goals and
decide which fights to avoid and which
are inevitable know how to control and
channel their emotions
this mindset is the only way to help one
bring equilibrium to their emotional
world and most probably the catalyst
that can lead to a proper way to deal
with human nature each individual is an
amalgamation of biological cultural and
social influences this complicated
mixture suggests that it is almost
impossible to find individuals whose
opinions can align perfectly we're all
humans trying to balance individuality
with togetherness and that's not an easy
task kant has said
act in such a way that you treat
humanity whether in your own person or
in the person of any other never merely
as a means to an end but always at the
same time as an end what he actually
means is that the way we treat each
other impacts our understanding of
morality a means to an end means a thing
that is not valued or important in
itself but
is useful in achieving an aim when you
meet someone and instead of identifying
the humanity in them you try to exploit
them benefit from them or just use them
then you treat them as means instead he
suggests that we should identify that
each human is a peculiar idiosyncratic
figure and we should treat them always
as ants in themselves see the humanity
in your fellow humans and the world
becomes a playground oozing
effervescence and synergy after all we
are all part of the same playground
called life i guess it is important to
learn how to play
hey guys hope you enjoyed today's video
if you did make sure to like subscribe
turn on notifications and comment below
something cool please so that more
people can discover it
if you want to watch more videos from my
channel check out this one and this one
take care see you soon adrian out